abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
var
yani ben bu yeni dünya düzeninde biraz
nasıl ayakta kalacağız ne olacak işin bu
tarafında Duran birisiyim Eğer Çünkü
reklam kökenliyim Ben aslında reklamcım
ilk başta bir reklam ajansı kurdum daha
sonra onu Global Network benden satın
aldığı Daha sonra ben kendime yetenek
odaklı başka bir hypers adında başka bir
şirket kurdum beş senede do şirketi
idare ediyorum temelde Aslında
çocukluktan beri yaptığım aynı iş diye
tanımladığım şey şunu içerik üreticiliği
Aslında temelde Şimdi biz kamera önünde
olmayan insanları içeri Küresi değilmiş
gibi bir etiket yapıştırıyoruz ama
aslında içeriği birileri üretiyor ya
sizin izlediğiniz şeylerin arkasında
Bazı stratejiler var bazı fikirler var
bu bir sürü çalışan insan var aslında
içeri Hepimiz bir şekilde içerik
üreticisi Siz bir kısmımız bunun
farkında bir kısmımız değil ben bu
konuşmada biraz şunu Anlatmaya
çalışacağım
hepimizde gelecek devasa bir içerik
üreticisi
ekonomisinin önünde duran insanlarız ve
çok yakın zamanda bütün bu dijital
dönüşüm şok fazla kratere
yaratıcı insana ve içerik üreticisi ne
ihtiyaç duyacak şu an bile öyle Şu an
sizin Takip ettiğiniz bundan iki sene
önce 10 tane insan vardı belki ya da iki
sene çok gerçekçi olmadı beş sene önce
20 tane insanı takip ediyorsunuz şimdi
bugün en az 1000 tane 1500 tane insanı
tanır hale geldiniz ve hepsi size farklı
noktalardan bazı eğlence getiriyor bazı
haber ve babası başka bir şey getiriyor
Dolayısıyla hayatınızı bir sürü insan
enjekte oldu aslında Ve bu çok nesil
şekilde büyümeye devam edecek buradan
başlıyorum anlatmaya ama temelde
anlatacağım şey dediğim gibi hepiniz
kendi hayatlarınızda nasıl içerik
üreticilerine dönüşe bilirsiniz bu
olacak Çünkü dediğim gibi bu bu yeni
dünya düzeninin çok fazla içerik üretme
ihtiyacı var ve Bu sistemin dışında
kalmak isterseniz de
harika bir hayat yok biraz bundan
bahsedeceğim benim dediğim gibi şu an
halpuz düğme diye adında bir ajansın var
ve bu çatı altında yaklaşık 100'e yakın
yetenek var ve biz de kamera arkasında
neredeyse yüz kişilik bir ekibiz ve bu
insanların daha içerik üretmesi için
çalışan bir ekip olduk ve böyle bir yeni
Medya Ajansı diye bir kavram ortaya
çıktı Biz de bunun 2 o üzerinden biri
oldu su bile iki sene sonra sıkıntıya
girebilir yiyeceğiniz her şey sıkıntıya
girebilir aynı şekilde izleyeceğiz
tüketicinin her şey Dolayısıyla hayata
böyle oo penceresinden değil de biraz
daha gerçekçi Pencereden bakmak istersek
geriye dönmemiz gerekiyor geriye
döndüğümde Mesela şunu anlatmak
istiyorum ve üretim dönemi 1800'lerde
dönüyorum beşe bölerek anlatacağım size
bugüne 5 adımda geleceğim üretim dönemi
nedir
1.850 lerin başından başlayıp 1950'lerin
başına kadar kilo Sanayi sanayi devrimi
hikâyesinde en önemli şey neydi He
üretmek ve onu ulaştırmak Çünkü zaten o
kapitalist düzenle bir şeyi üretip
ulaştırabilir yorsan zaten bir marka
oluyordum ve bunu devletler arkasında
durdu bu üretimi yollarını bu aradılar
buldular çünkü bu Üretim yapmak çok zor
ve o dönemin şartlarında pahalı bir
şeydi ve bunu yapabilenler devasa
markalara dönüştü Aslında
daha sonra
1950'lerin başında Aslında satış
dönemine geçtik Ne oldu artık üretim o
kadar da zor bir şey olmaktan çıktı
sonra ne oldu satış odaklı şirketler
oluşmaya başladı Yani o bildiğimiz
şirketler o üretim şirketlerinin kocaman
satış departmanları olmaya başladı neden
bu sefer ürün var bunu ne kadar fazla
pazara taşırsak o kadar fazla para
kazanacaktı Bu şirketler ne yaptılar
gittiler dünyanın en ücra köşesine kadar
okokokok olayı götürdüler başka ürünleri
götürdüler hiç hayatınızda ilk defa
gittiğiniz en ücra yerlerde bile o
tabelaları starbucksları vesaitleri
görmeye başladın
mm yılların başına kadar aslında
bu Global dev markalar oluşmaya başladı
ve dediğim gibi konu satış tıbbi Peki
olayı ne değiştirdi Tabii ki internet
şimdi bu satış odaklı şirketler sağ
gittikleri yere bunu sata biliyorlardı
ama başka da kipi şirket hiç gitmeden
internette Oraya ulaşabilme başladı
Hayda bu sefer Oyun değişti Bu sefer
artık pazarlama Ana Konu olmaya başladı
satış döneminde 4p diye bir kavram
vardır pazarlama kavramı o pazarlama
döneminde 7p ye dönüştü ulaştılar
sattılar reklamlar reklamlar reklamlar
2000'li yılların o ilk 10 senesine 15
senesini düşünün heryerden reklam
fırlayan o siteleri açtığınızda
suratınıza suratınıza bütün Ben arıların
çarptığı her türlü reklam modelinin
insanları ikrar eden ek o önüne çıkan
dönem İşte bu pazarlama yoğun olan dönem
bu kadar reklama karşı tüketicinin
tepkisi ne oluyor ilk başta
verimli olmaya başlıyor reklamlar
gitgide verim düşüyor düşüyor düşüyor
düşüyor en son artık öyle bir noktaya
geliyor ki izleyici tüketici bu satın
almıyor artık Yani bu gördüğü şeyden
etkilenmiyor de ne oluyor o reklam
modeli yavaş yavaş çöp olmaya başlıyor
büyük o Global appler Var ya herkesin
cebinde ilk dönemde Hiçbirinde reklam
yoktu çünkü bunlar
2010'ların ortasından sonra artık hayata
geçmiş yeni dönem şirketler Onlar dedi
ki Arkadaşlar
ben sizi reklamı Bu olmayacağım Sakin
olun Ben size içerik getirdim Siz bu
içeriye alıp severseniz Ben de arada
size reklam yaparım ve bir kreatif
ekonomi desteklediler Aslında o kıyafeti
ve ekonomi bu destekle yeni bir kavram
ortaya çıkardılar stratejik pazarlama ve
ben artık 2010'ların ortasından Sonra
şöyle marka yaratabiliyor du Çok
enteresan Hala da yapılabilen şeyden
bahsediyor bir tane şu an marka ismi
düşüneyim çorap şu an Tolga çorapları
yapacağım benim çoraba dokunmama bile
gerek yok Biliyor musunuz bakın Ben
çorapları görmüyorum artık bir çorap
markası sahibi olarak bu çok fazla şey
değiştirdi bakın tam tersinden
bahsediyorum ne oluyordu satış döneminde
Eğer üretebiliyor samsata biliyordum
Şimdi bu prosesin hiçbir anlamı kalmadı
artık herkes erişilebilir oldu Pazaryeri
dediğimiz web sitelere İşte o Eğer beğen
Biler Amazonlar yani Amazonlar
güçlendiği zamandan bahsediyorsun
Türkiye'de bir sürü bildiğiniz pazar
yeri var herşeyin pazar yeri var artık
araba mı Arabanın satıldığı yere mi şu
an satıldığı yer işte başka Tekstil onun
Pazaryeri her şey pazar yerinde satıldı
Çünkü artık satın alacak insanın piraz
daha azı kadar üreten insan var Yani
markası olan insan var Bu da yeni bir
dönem getirdi pazaryerleri dönemi Evet
şimdi tane tane son noktaya geldik Şu an
olduğumuz dönem s
bundan sonraki dönemin başlangıcı
Aslında bu web 01 web02 ye geçmişlik
Pazar yerleriyle şimdi w03 a geçiyoruz
Şimdi artık size deneyim satmaya
başlayacaklar
nedense deneyim saçaklar biliyor musun
diğer bütün Fiziksel aktiviteler çok zor
gideceğim işte Çine haber vereceğim
şimdiden biri o çorabı üretecek oradan
oraya yollayacak Tamam yapabiliyorum ama
ne gerek var Onun yerine birbirimize
dijital şeyler satalım sokmayalım
Lojistik ile uğraşmayalım gümrükle
uğraşmayalım
büyük devasa fonlar dünyayı fonlayan Bu
gördüğünüz bütün şirketlerin sahibi olan
fonlar artık bunları yapmak istemiyor
bu ve size yeni bir alan yeni bir pazar
yeri veriyor O da metaverse dediğimiz
kavram aslında yani bu metal orta
bütün bu şu ana kadar üretilen şeylerin
minik minik dijital versiyonları ile
karşılaşacaksınız ve son o sistemin
kendi dinamiği olan ürünleri satın
almaya başlayacaksınız vb şu an
cebinizden atıyorum bir ay içerisinde
3000 lira para çıkıyorsa ya da 10 bin
lira para çıkıyorsa ya da birim olarak
söyleyeyim 11'in para çıkıyorsa bunun üç
sene sonra 4 birimi 5 birimi artık
dijital ürünlere çıkmaya başlayacak
Çünkü bu çok daha verimli
O kim için verimli bunu satanlar için
verimli
Dolayısıyla ben şu an size bir
dönüşümden bahsediyorum Ama bu dönüşüm
aslında Zaten
sizin de evde oturup Hani bundan sonraki
adım ne olurdu deseniz aklınıza gelen
şeylerden bahsediyorum Bunlar uç
örnekler Değil Hayal değil bundan 2-3
sene sonra başımıza gelecek şeyler ve
dediğim gibi birçok şeyi artık dijital
satın alacaksınız bir sürü meslek yok
olacak
gözünüzün önünde
diyeceksiniz ya vallahi Selam şu vardı
bu vardı Şu an yoklar mesela Avrupa'da
şu an hizmet sektörünün birçoğunu
insansız hale getirirler birçok noktada
insan yok şu an şu an kodla menü
bakıyoruz bundan bir yaşama sonra
siparişi doğrudan versek çok şaşırır
mısınız ya da Online olarak
eğitimi veren kurumlar şunu da şaşırır
mısın ya o Fiziksel eğitim vermek çok
masraflı biz ya bu yirmi fiziksel
verelim de yüzde yetmiş bunu Online'a
çekelim yada yüzde seksen Online'a
çekelim dese Bu nereden çıktı demezsiniz
artık o alıştık alışıyoruz ve bir video
çekiyorum online eğitimde
100.000 tane insana 1 milyon taneyi Sana
gösteriyorum Ben şimdi bir milyon insanı
eğiteceğim diye nasıl bir fiziksel
enerji ortaya koymalıyım Düşünsenize hem
satan için Karlı hem alın için Karlı
diye düşünüyoruz ve sistem kendini
Buraya doğru içecek Eskiden mesaj şimdi
müzikle ilgili şunu diyorlardı ya aynı
sistem olacak bak ya plaktan müzik
dinlemek ne kadar güzeldi ne kadar iyi
bir ses alıyordu kalite olarak da şu
anki kalitenin çok üstünde bir ses
duyuyorduk Okey haklı
ama o şekilde dünyanın her yerine müziği
yollayamıyorum zor
Ne yani şimdi çok daha kalitesiz bir ses
dökümanını dünyanın her yerine yollaya
biliyorum hangisini sistem tercih eder
Tabii ki kalitesi olan tercih eder Tabii
ki dünyanın her yerine sata bildiğini
tercih eder Yani bunun önüne
geçemezsiniz Bu bir şekilde doğal
Seleksiyon gibi her şey adım adım
dijital ekaya kaymak zorunda kayacak
aldığınız şeylerde oto kayacak Yani
şöyle şu an çocuğunuzun mesela çok fazla
kıyafet ihtiyacı olduğundan şikayet
ediyor olabilirsiniz yakında alacağı
kıyafetleri giyemeyecek bile
dijital kıyafetler olacak Ve siz kafayı
yiyeceksiniz Sen giyiyorsun bile bunu
nasıl alırsın diye Ya da sevdiği bir
inficon Sırrın suratını ona telif
ödeyerek satın alacak bu ve kendi
oyununda sevdiğin film Sırrın suratıyla
o oyunu ya da o verse gezmek isteyecek
yani şu an harcanan paranın çok büyük
bir kısmı cüzdan değiştirecek dijital
cüzdana doğru kayacak yiyeceklerin gen
etiyle oynayacaklar daha farklı daha
besleyici daha doyurucu oluyor yeni
gıdalar besinler ortaya çıkacak ve
bunlar çok ciddi insana ulaşacak ve
Belki siz içinizden diyeceksiniz gibi
çıktı bunlar çünkü bunlar çıkmasaydı şu
kadar şey de bu kadar insanı ulaşamaz
the kaynı Az önce bahsettiğim plak ve şu
anki müzik dağıtım sistemi gibi herşey
size mantıklı gelecek adım adım ama
herşey çok daha dijital bir yere gidecek
sanayi devrimi bahsettiğim satış
pazarlama dönemi
Pardon üretim dönemi yüz sene sürmüş
satış dönemi 50 sene pazarlama dönemi 10
sene ve gitgide süreç hızlanıyor Çünkü
teknoloji her tarafından ilerlemeye
başlıyor iki tane seçenek olacak
elimizde bunun birincisi bu değişen
ekonomiye uygun
mesleklerinin işte hepimiz çoluğumu
çocuğumu o yönde yetiştireceğiz veya
kendimizde yeteneklerimizi bu yönde
kullanmaya başlayacağız bir kere zaten
çocuk ilkokulda yazılımı öğrenmek
zorunda olacak
Ortaokulda tiridi öğrenecek vesaire
derken bütün bu dijital sisteme Entegre
olacak ama onlar bunu okuyacak Biz arada
bir nesiliz Ya biz ne yapacağız
bize bu eğitim ya da bu yapıları Entegre
olamayan kısım için o bizi de
düşünecekler merak etmeyin evde
Gözlüklerim izle bir şekilde ufak ufak
satın alacağız ne yapacağız işte
koyun mayling yapacağız
Sen hiç hareket etmeden bir sürü bize
ufak ufak paralar kazanabileceğimiz
şeyler verecekler oyuncaklar verecekler
onlarla Mini kova 100 dolar kazandım 200
bugün falan diye aşırı sevineceğiz
Bu da bir yol Tabi milyarlarca insan bu
saygının içinde kalacak bir kısım
bunların
geliştirmesini yapacak bak klasik
mesleklerde olan da çok küçük bir kısım
Tabii ki kalacak bak ama Joker imiz şu
bu sayede büyüyen devasa bir kreatif
ekonomi var aslında klasik reklam
anlayışı Aslında bitti Şimdi insanlara
artık o markaların bağıra çağıra belirle
ulaştığı dönem ortadan kalktı Artık
insanın insandan başka güvence kimse
kalmadı şu an çok güvendiğim biri bir
şey önermediği sürece benim onu bir
Reklamdan görüp al Almam çok zor
ve bu şekilde aslında bu insanların
marka değeri yükselmeye başladı
Şu an Bilmiyorum farkında mısınız
Eskiden çok fazla
güvendiğimiz ve çok fazla hayatımıza
aldığımızı kurumsal markalar yerine
insanları
markalaşması tercih ediyoruz Dolayısıyla
insana güvenimiz çok yüksek bu önemli
bir nokta bu hepimizin kredi ve
ekonomideki yerini sağlamlaştıran şey
aslında
burada insanların kendi kişisel
hikayelerini
topluluklara ulaştırmasının önemi çok
artıyor Yani ben senin hikayeni
gerçekten bilirsem ve Senin Hikayen
hakikaten bana alacağın bir şey varsa
onu bana ulaştırır San ben onu satın
alıyorum Yeterki onu bana ulaştırabilir
içimizdeki hikayeleri ve içerik
üreticilerine
bulabiliriz ve bunları doğru şekilde o
rasyonu yapabiliriz Ve çok daha fazla
insan ulaştırabiliriz çok enteresan
Finans tiplerini aldıkları bir sürü
hesap var orada ünlü finanslar var yani
şu an bankada İçinizde çalışan Finans
tarafında çalışan bir sürü insan vardır
büyük ihtimalle kendini küçücük bir
Kapital belirle S 500 TL bile olur 500
TL'ye alsa her gün çeşitli uygulamalar
yapıp bunu minik minik içerik leştir s
hemen bir komünist olmaya başlıyor Hemen
onu izleyen hemen ona yorum yapan onu
öyle mi yaptın bunu böyle mi yaptım
vesaire derken bir anda orada bir
konuşma Bir kitle oluşuyor Eğer sen
onlara doğru hitap edersen doğru şekilde
içerik servis edersen bir bakıyorsun ki
Sen onların inficon Sırrı lideri figürü
ikonu olmuşsun Bunlar çok zor değil şunu
unutmayalım sadece bir parantez olarak
hakkaten yaptığınız Her işin ya da Sahip
olduğunuz her bobinin bir içeri
karşılığı bu ve doğru istediğinizde
sizden dinleyecek çok Hikayemiz var
Kendi hikayeleriniz edebildiğiniz Exper
olduğunuz konulara da bu şekilde tekrar
başka bir perspektifle bakabilirsiniz
Biz zaten sosyal medyada sınız zaten
çıkmıyorsunuz oradan zaten günümüzün
altı saati 10 saati orada geçiyor
Dolayısıyla burada tüketici olmaktansa
üretici olmayı tercih etmek zaten bundan
sonraki evre için hepiniz adına çok
faydalı bir karar olur
Burada sadece İki cümle söyleyeceğim bir
karar eşiğinde iseniz herhangi bir anda
olursanız veya sadece şunu düşünmenizi
istiyorum
eskisi hala gerçekten bir seçenek mi
çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]